brought to you by Final Fantasy 15
available on PlayStation 4 and Xbox one
November 29th is this the real life is
it just Final Fantasy 15 I've waited 10
years to say that joke was it worth it
absolutely the newest entry in Square
Enix is premiere RPG series has been in
development for so long that it started
to feel like a pipe dream but seeing as
this episode of reality check is brought
to you by Final Fantasy 15 I guess it's
time to wake up and smell the Geisel
greens to celebrate the imminent release
of the game I thought I'd inject some
reality into the fantasy by taking a
look at some of the real-life
counterparts and inspirations for the
things that you'll see in it so this is
Final Fantasy 15 in real life or at
least some aspects of it it's a very big
[Music]
to get around in 15 you take your dad's
car out for a spin
less than a hundred were made noctus his
father spent three years restoring this
car it is his love it is his passion
this is a very forced Ferris Bueller
reference while the regalia looks just
like a casual special edition OD r8 v10
towards the end of the game it joins the
lofty ranks of chitty-chitty-bang-bang
and the convertible at the end of Greece
and by that I mean it can fly yep you
actually get a flying car and if you
think that this is the point in the
video where Final Fantasy has gone too
damn far then shut the front door
because I'm about to blow your damn mind
a flying car already exists this is the
Aero 'mobile part car pop plane part
transformer from conception to creation
it took the Slovakian company 20 years
to build a working prototype and has
been in flight testing since 2013 just
like a normal car it uses gasoline and
can fit in parking bays so you can take
it for a quick run to the shops but
unlike a normal car it has folded wings
that extend out and can then be airborne
so after you've picked up that pint of
milk you can cruise in the clouds for a
bit
there's even an autopilot and in case of
emergency it comes with a parachute so
while 15 may be a work of fiction flying
cars are a reality there are aiming to
release in 2018 so better start saving
another huge element often quite
literally these guys are huge a Final
Fantasy R summons in 15 they're called
Astral's and noctus can call on them for
aid in battle
now these Astral's have pretty
fantastical origins in myths and legends
so here 3 of my favorites
Leviathan has appeared in many Final
Fantasy games
it's a fearsome sea serpent that calls
on a massive body of water to damage
those in its path it's been confirmed
that she will be a summon in 15 but only
if a body of water is nearby the concept
of Leviathan has been around for
hundreds of years even being referenced
in the Bible sometimes Leviathan is a
metaphor for the sheer size and power of
God's abilities other times it's
interpreted as a demon associated with
the devil which could explain its
snake-like
depiction in art either way massive cool
dragon of the sea
Bahamut is a colossal dragon inspired by
ancient Arabian mythology or it's a
giant fish that supports the earth it's
so immense that humans can't bear to
look at it but how do bar Matt go from a
fish to a dragon that we know from final
fantasy well you've got Dungeons and
Dragons created Gary Gygax to thank for
that one in 1977's Monster Manual he
refers to bar Matt as the platinum
dragon king of the good dragons which is
why Final Fantasy which borrowed a lot
from Dungeons and Dragons went with
Dragon instead of planet carrying fish
Titan is an ode to Greek mythology the
Titans were deities that preceded the
Olympian gods birth from the union
between the earth known as Gaia and sky
which is why Titans main attack guy as
Wrath does massive earth elemental
damage to enemies and generally ruins
the landscape all around it crystals are
powerful legendary items in our mainstay
in Final Fantasy in 15 you play as knock
disks crown prince of the kingdom of
Lucis home to the last magical crystal
in the world this crystal is what gives
noctus the ability to wield magic and
while there's no peer-reviewed
scientific evidence that crystals in
real life can do that scientists at IBM
in Zurich have managed to use crystals
in a way that's kind of magical super
impressive but mostly terrifying the
human brain is amazing using relatively
low amounts of energy its sift through
an unfathomable amount of sensory inputs
like touch and smell to determine what's
important in engineering they're trying
to emulate the brain and sensory nervous
system to help efficiently process huge
data sets earlier this year
IBM made a huge breakthrough
successfully making a computer chip that
mimics the behavior of a human brain
cell all with a crystal okay it's way
more complicated than that but the basic
gist is that because it's a crystal when
it gets hit by incoming information
which arrives as a pulse of energy it
changes state to become more glass like
once a certain amount of information
arrives this chip fires and passes the
information on the glass legs day then
reverts back to a crystal but this
Reformation is slightly randomized
so the crystal is different each time
and you can never predict when it's next
going to fire this unpredictability is
what makes it just like a human brain
cell which behaves similarly the
researchers say that this kind of chip
can be used for processing huge
quantities of information such as the
astronomic data that comes from the
world's largest telescope financial
transactions or even filtering through
social media while we're not spewing
fire from our fingertips just yet using
crystals to make a computer chip that
behaves just like a human brain cell is
pretty damn cool so there we are some
really cool stuff from final fantasy 15
in real life but more videos like this
one make sure to LIKE and subscribe to
GameSpot and for more of me I'm over on
Twitter at Lucy James games I'll see you
next time
[Music]